just days after the FCC's net neutrality
repeal was enacted which was on Monday
CNN is reporting that a TN t--'s buyout
of Time Warner which owned CNN has been
approved by a judge and we're descending
even further into what I'm calling media
consolidation dystopia and I first
reported to you who knows what I mean
late 2016 that AT&T made a deal to buy
Time Warner for 85 billion dollars some
people are calling it a merger it's
really a buyout but effectively it is
the coming together of these two
companies I think it's okay to call it a
merger even though legally speaking
that's not what it is I told you that
this deal would be a disaster for
consumers okay it would be bad for
competition it would raise prices it
would reduce choice and I told you at
the time that there should be legal
challenges to that merger or buy out and
there were including from the Trump
administration although possibly for
personally vindictive reasons rather
than questions of antitrust but a judge
yesterday has ruled in favor of the
buyout AT&T now says they're gonna close
the deal out by June 20th this is days
away the judge even said don't bother
bother with Appeals because appeals
would be unjust in this particular case
and we know that Donald Trump has had
been at least sort of nominally opposed
to the buyout but it's mostly because
the guy doesn't like CNN and Time Warner
is owned by CNN but nevertheless it's
happening despite Trump's wishes despite
my wishes and a lot of other people's
wishes this is going to happen and
content that is produced by Netflix and
Amazon which for all the criticisms that
we can have about Netflix and Amazon
Netflix and Amazon were causing
cord-cutting people canceling cable
right that was putting some competitive
pressure on the big cable providers
Netflix and Amazon are now going to be
potentially hurt by this buyout AT&T
could if they wanted give their own
content right like Time Warner content
soon to be priority and then charged
more to Netflix or to Netflix users to
use their bandwidth you want to pay
or for Netflix or do you want to watch
Time Warner content and lots of people
will say I'm already getting gouged by
AT&T I'm not gonna pay even more to be
able to watch Netflix content without
constant rebuffering I don't know you
could say I'll cancel my cable and just
buy internet from AT&T well then your
internet becomes much more expensive
because you no longer have a bundled
package and it's still Netflix calm that
could be slowed down or deprioritize so
good luck with that
and we have in the last I guess 72 hours
the inaction of the net neutrality
repeal and even more media consolidation
consumers are going to have a very bad
time and I wonder and I'm not asking
this rhetorically I genuinely wonder
what is CNN's coverage of net neutrality
going to look like after this buyout
then I remembered oh right they barely
covered it to begin with so I guess
that's not going to change much we're
still not gonna hear a damn thing about
net neutrality from CNN or Time Warner
or AT&T and this is only going to
continue this is a signal if you are
Comcast which is potentially going to be
buying part of Fox or Disney which also
wants to buy part of Fox or is trying to
already if you see this decision from
the judge and you see the direction that
this is going it's a green light for
even further consolidation and we've
been tracking and participating in the
rise of independent media for years
right we are an independent media
program we've been covering independent
media and there are two forces which
could completely decimate our industry
it's not even really an industry it's
more of a niche number one getting rid
of net neutrality just happened right
decided months ago enacted on Monday and
more media consolidation happening and
more is coming and if you want just like
a little hint as to how the future of
these mega mergers is going to go look
at the fact that the judge in this case
imposed no additional conditions on AT&T
buying time warner the judge just said
sounds good to me and don't even bother
appealing so this is
it I don't know what else to call it
then a Red Alert dystopia yeah it's
really bad and maybe et and Time Warner
don't have a monopoly on the industry
but telecommunications is so big of an
industry and impacts so many people in
so many different ways you may get your
news through it you may connect with
people on it may get entertained by it
and so it's really upsetting that you
know fewer and fewer voices are gonna be
heard from all of us I think you know
Comcast owns what is it NBC and then
Viacom and CBS may be getting together
to I think we're gonna see a lot more of
this it is the exact sort of cautionary
tale that for about 25 years really I
mean at least 22 years since the 1996
Telecommunications Act but really 25 or
even 30 years media serious media
analysts and academics have been warning
about and it's happening your media will
become more expensive you will have to
work harder to find alternative media
the distributors of media as Pat is
pointing out are increasingly going to
be the producers of media as well and if
you're if you're hoping that now I get
to Pat silver linings that people
sometimes hear or me telling you what to
do to fix this I don't know right I mean
I'd say contact your representatives
except they're mostly ok with this stuff
Democrats did vote for net neutrality
but really all of them part complicit in
the status quo that's being perpetuated
vote them out then right I don't know
what else to say
yeah it's a call to action to support
the shows that you like the specific
websites you like and you know maybe
supporting independent media shows like
ours very nice I like that Pat Pat's now
getting in on the indirect references to
membership in patreon but seriously I
actually don't have good news I like to
try to wrap up the story with some at
least cautiously optimistic something
and I don't have it because it's really
really getting bad the video you just
finished watching was made possible by
you through the membership program you
can sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership